françois bayrou il dit que la france
traverse la plus grave crise qu'elle ait
connue depuis la guerre et c'est jusqu'à
9h sur bfm tv et rmc passé une
excellente journée nous on sera là
demain à 6 heures à demain à demain
[Musique]
bonjour françois bayrou il est 8h30 3
sur rmc et bfm tv françois bayrou vous
êtes le haut commissaire au plan vous
êtes président du modem vous êtes maire
de pau et un vent glacial sur la france
des prévisions très sombre énergétique
économique morale on commence à
comprendre ce que peut-être emmanuel
macron voulait dire quand il a dit qu'il
faudrait qu'on paye le prix de notre
liberté et de nos valeurs on va y
revenir planification et rationnement
voilà ce qu'a dit la première ministre
hier planification c'est vous la france
va vers la plus grave crise qu'elle ait
connue depuis la guerre c'est votre
pronostic est-ce qu'on va vers cette
crise ou est ce qu'en fait on y est déjà
donc va vers une crise mais il faut
corriger les parfois les titres de
journaux sont trop rapides c'est d'une
crise mondiale pas une crise nationale
française
c'est une crise mondiale c'est une crise
mondiale qui vient de ce que un
événement absolument inattendu le
déclenchement d'une guerre terrestre sur
le sol européen une guerre de d'annexion
un pays libre par son puissant voisin ce
qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis hitler
cette guerre là à perturber renverser
tous les équilibres économiques et ça
tombe dans une période où en même temps
les autres locomotives du monde la chine
les etats unis en europe c'était
l'allemagne sont toutes les trois en
difficulté
et dans un contexte d'inflation qu'on
n'avait pas connu depuis 40 ans dans il
ya un cocktail de toutes les crises
possible en main il ya il y à une
addition de
2,2 risque inédit de menace sans
précédent qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis
longtemps et
président de la république et le
gouvernement ont bien raison d'essayer
de préparer les réponses j'imagine bien
d'ailleurs que lorsque vous avez
prononcé cette phrase sur la crise la
plus grave qu'on ait connu depuis la
guerre c'était concomitant avec cette
phrase d' emmanuel macron sur la fin
abondance et la fin de l'insouciance
vous étiez sans doute coordonnées on
imagine bien et c'est votre rente nos
politiques non mais vous vous partager
le même diagnostic la question c'est la
réponse quand vous avez visa bête bornes
ir qui menacent de rationnement qui dit
au fond il faudra faire un effort les
entreprises doivent baisser de 10 % leur
consommation d'électricité sous peine de
black out je voudrais que voulait
coucher
si nous agissons collectivement nous
pouvons surmonter ce risque de pénurie
mais si chacun ne prend pas sa part ou
que toutes les hypothèses défavorable se
conjuguer nous serions amenés à imposer
des baisses de consommation
si nous devions en arriver au
rationnement les entreprises seraient
les premières touchées et nous devons
malheureusement nous y préparer nous
devons nous préparer au rationnement on
en est là je pense que des décisions
collectives et individuelles entreprise
par entreprise et même dans les familles
ces décisions là peuvent écarter le
risque de rationnement c'est tout le
sens de ce petit le gouvernement va
enregistrer sous fond du racialisme en
réseau et on agit fera rien
si on est un peuple
qui veut jouer son rôle d'une société
puissante avec des créateurs puissant
dans le monde si on est une société
comme ça alors il faut être capable de
regarder les choses en face et il faut
le faire sans affolement parce que nous
sommes en même temps un dpi sites
probables bien sans abonnement c'est
difficile quand des pays qui est le
mieux armé pour faire face à tout ça ne
serait ce que parce que nous avons une
capacité de production de l'électricité
nucléaire que heureusement nous avons
sauvé et que heureusement nous avons
pris la décision de porter dans l'avenir
enfin pardon arrêtons nous un instant
quand même là dessus parce que quand on
apprend qu'il ya trente deux réacteurs
sur 56 qui sont à l'arrêt qui sont à
l'arrêt pour maintenance
vous êtes précisément à la planification
ça n'était pas possible d'anticiper de
pas arrêter tous les réacteurs en même
temps c'était tout à fait possible
d'anticiper mais elle souvenez-vous les
gouvernements successifs les
gouvernements qui ont précédé celui ci
et la présidence d' emmanuel macron ce
tous ces gouvernements là était sur
l'idée et les médias aussi qu'il fallait
à tout prix fermer les centrales
nucléaires que ces têtes bleues ça
l'avenir et qu'on nous annonce emmanuel
macron qui a fermé fait ça il va donc
sans doute ça c'est pas les médias
les décisions de dessenheim été prises
avant et on sait très bien par le
gouvernement précédent des sous la
pression quand même françois sous la
pression d'une opinion l'engagement une
décision c'est sous la pression d'une
opinion dont on savait à l'époque où
dante ont
vérifié à l'époque qu'elle était sur
l'idée que le nucléaire c'était fini or
c'est la seule source d'énergie qui nous
permettent en même temps de développer
des renouvelables et de garantir qu'on
aura pas d'accident de prôner sûr quand
même dire qu'aujourd'hui la menace d'un
black out ou peut-être de coupures de
courant temporaire tournant dans
différentes régions de france il le faut
au creux de l'hiver c'est aussi dû à ses
32 réacteurs qui sont à l'arrêt oui mais
on est en train j'imagine en tout cas ce
que je lis les déclarations des
responsables
ils ont découvert un phénomène de
corrosion et ils sont en train de le
réparer le plus rapidement possible pour
que avant le 1er décembre pour une
partie des unités et avant le 1er
janvier pour l'autre partie
le plus possible de tranches redémarre
bon c'est bien qu'il vaille à la
sécurité en même temps qu'est ce qu'on
dirait si veillée pas la sécurité donc
de ce point de vue là il y a eu un
aveuglement de l'opinion française
toutes tendances confondues
pendant des années et des années qui en
fait aller vers le renoncement au
nucléaire
alors que c'est la seule énergie qui ne
pollue en rien par rejets de gaz à effet
de serre et donc la voilà en amont à
renverser les choses ya eu une prise de
conscience est aujourd'hui
le plan a participé à cette prise de
conscience je suis venu en parler à
votre micro en indiquant que le combat
pour les renouvelables et le combat pour
le nucléaire c'était la même chose
françois bayrou parmi les pistes
également pour faire baisser les effets
de gaz pour essayer aussi de réguler la
question de l'énergie c'est de taxer les
super profits pour récupérer de l'argent
notamment on pense à total l'italie le
fait l'espagne le fait la grande
bretagne le fait est ce qu'il faut le
faire bon c'est une décision du
gouvernement moi je suis pas obsédé par
la chasse aux entreprises qui ont une
période dans laquelle ça va mieux ou
bien pour elle mais s'il faut de la
solidarité il en faudra et on peut tout
neuf être
tout à fait ouvrir le dialogue avec les
entreprises mais le vous frayer bien le
la question ça n'est pas de punir et
entre les entreprises grecques avant
dire oui c'est pas avec eux qu'il faut
dialoguer là non ça dépend il se trouve
que je pense que fait à la tête de cette
fois
là
vous voyez ce en fait vous ouvrir un
très grand chapitre
est ce qu'on est capable en france de
faire partager des questions des défis à
des acteurs aussi différents que les
entreprises et le pouvoir exécutif
ma conviction c'est que oui à une
condition d'aujourd'hui ma conviction
c'est que oui on peut dans une démarche
de de prise de conscience civique et
c'est à sage que le président de la
république pense lorsqu'il parle de
refondation
on peut
dialoguer eux discuter échanger
négocier avec les grandes entreprises
les moyennes entend négocier avec un
petit peu le couteau sous la tente quand
même pas ce qu'on leur dit soit vous
baisser de 10% votre consommation
soit on va quand même vous
réquisitionner les parties de
l'électricité essayons de ne pas
totalement simplifier on a une crise
énergétique tel qu'on en a pas eu depuis
des années 70 vous souvenez de la grande
crise à cette époque du pétrole et le
moment on disait la france n'a pas de
pétrole mais elle a des idées et et tous
les gouvernants les uns après les autres
depuis pompidou jusque agissent car à
cette époque venait pour dire il y a des
moyens de conserver l'activité tout en
baissant sa consommation énergétique ces
moyens-là observations de ceux qui
traitent avec moi à pau le savent très
bien je plaide toujours pour que on est
une démarche active sur ce sujet là
parce qu'on peut avoir les mêmes
activités avec 10% donc pour 15% vous
êtes trop
d'électricité par les entreprises parmi
je le disais les solutions il ya cette
idée de taxer les superprofits il
yal'idée aussi d'interdire les jets les
jets privés oui ou non non mais
on a l'impression parfois
je dis ça avec ces personnes qu'on est
un pays qui marche sur la tête
quelle déception des avions des écolos
mais en l'occurrence le ministre russe
des sports clément bo n'a pas l'air
d'être fermé idée permettez-moi se
prononcer sur ce sujet a même dit ces
personnes
il ya des courants d'opinion qui pensent
si on veut conserver les acquis sociaux
qui sont les nôtres dans un pays qui est
le plus généreux au monde sans doute du
point de vue de la prise en charge de
l'éducation de la santé
des garanties sur le chômage des
garanties sur les retraites tout ce que
nous savons parfaitement dans la vie de
tous les jours et près famille si on
veut conserver ses acquis là bas il faut
qu'on produise faut qu'on est chez nous
des créateurs d'entreprise fo koné chez
nous des créateurs d'activités produire
il faut en effet bien des créateurs
d'emplois et il faut que la france
apparaisse comme un pays qui est
favorable à cette activité de
deux créations et quelle est l'image
d'un pays qui dirait au chef
d'entreprise du monde qui viennent
investir en france vous n'avez pas le
droit de prendre un jet la dépense des
jets c'est infinitésimal dans de la
dépense des plus symboliques ses singles
uni et sa wii est le sien il est le
symbole pour l'image de la france qui
veut apparaître comme le pays où
l'activité est la plus soutenue ou la
création d'entreprise ou l'invention ou
la découverte de nous de nouveaux
procédés et la plus soutenue par les
têtes symbole vous le savez mieux de
personne vous êtes politique vous savez
que les symboles ils sont très
importants et un sens voilà c'est pas un
jet privé c'est un jet ski emmanuel
macron qui à la fin de l'été apparaît en
jet ski on connaît cette image là
beaucoup de tournées on peut la revoir
sur bfmtv du président sur un jet-ski
autour du fort de brégançon elle est
reprise en boucle par tous les
politiques ici même à ce micro
clémentine autant dès qu'il faut
critiquer le président elle ressort
cette image contre la semaine d'après il
dit c'est la fin de l'abondance et c'est
la fin d'un souciant ccja par un
décalage entre l'image et le son tout ça
est absolument ridicule c'est démago
s'appelait de tout ce que vous voulez
mais c'est ridicule la consommation d'un
jet ski c'est la consommation d'une moto
si le président de la république était
allé faire une heure de moto sur les
routes de brégançon est ce qu'il y
aurait de quoi dire que c'est un crime
puisque le mot a été utilisé
tout ça est ridicule on est entre qui
pollue mais ça pollue pas du tout eu sa
peau ligue ou comme une moto de la moto
vous même et donc je fais plus mais
c'est pas la question et dans l'es6 et
la question vous voyez faire du vélo ça
concerne c'est ce que disent les
opposants jeudi dernier les images l on
passe son temps on passe son temps à
substituer
l'accessoire à l'essentiel à mettre le
secondaire à la place de ceux qui doit
passer en premier on passe son temps à
intoxiquer l'opinion avec des sujets qui
sont des sujets alors par mois les
anciens dire ridicule parlant
l'essentiel parlant de l'école vous avez
été ministre d'édification vous avez
toujours dit que l'école c'était le
pilier de la démocratie et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec cette pénurie
de professeurs avec une vraie inquiétude
sur le nombre de professeurs qu'ils
eurent à face aux classes et quelle sera
leur niveau je voudrais que vous
écoutiez ce que l'une des journalistes
de bfm tv a fait elle a postulé pour un
job de professeurs alors qu'elle n'avait
qu'une licence at elle dit à ce qu'ils
voulaient et l'embauché et voilà le
dialogue qui a eu lieu alors qu'elle
postule à écouter est-ce qu'on fait des
cd des programmes du système et du fer
alors pas je connais pas encore alors on
n'en parlait pas concrètement au moment
où vous êtes à l'aise par exemple sur
l'extraction
à weesp accès à ça reste lointain avait
consulté le site
alors oui j'ai regardé mais en vraiment
dans les grandes villes c'est totalement
illusoire de de me tourner vers cette
dame enseignement où
elle a été embauchée je le précise à
l'académie de versailles après cet
entretien où pourtant elle répondait
systématiquement qu'elle n'était pas
vraiment prête est ce que ça vous
inquiète
j'ai écrit à 30 ans un livre qui
s'appelait la décennie des malappris
et qui disait qu'on allait
inéluctablement faire un accident comme
ça on a eu remond réagi à la fin des
années 90 au milieu et à la fin des
années 90 et puis c'est vrai qu'il y a
eu un glissement et ceci est le
probablement le plus grave la plus grave
des difficultés le plus lourd des défis
auxquels la france est à faire face
je disais qu'on était armé face à la
crise du monde on est seul on était armé
à l'exception du fait que pour l'instant
notre notre système éducatif est en
situation critique et koné oui obligé
d'embaucher
dans des job dating comme on dit c'est
parfois sur le bon coin comme on dit
aussi on est obligé en 30 minutes
embauché en 30 minutes des gens c'est ça
l'art face à nancy elle attendait
d'abord soyons pas méprisant elle a une
licence
ah non mais moi je serai à disent qu'ils
ont terminée vous savez ce que je suis
en licence parce que ce qui nous dit
qu'il faut une maîtrise pour passer le
concours et ceux qui n'ont pas réussi le
concours ça veut dire qu'on estimait
qu'il n'était pas en mesure d'être prof
on les rappelle mais vous avez
absolument raison et j'en ai parlé
longuement avec le ministre de
l'éducation sur des cas précis
c'est une c'est une situation qui est
qui ne peut pas être acceptée mais avec
une licence licence ça voulait dire les
cascades de kendy c'est à dire on vous
avez la liberté d'enseigner c'est la
minute latin savannah une licence bon
donc ce ne sont pas des personnalités
qui sont totalement désarmés si vous
avez une licence est normalement que
vous avez franchi un certain nombre des
degrés donc nous soyons pas méprisant
mais qu'il faille reconstruire
profondément une stratégie générale pour
le monde éducatif c'est une série très
inquiétant dans vos propos à la fois sur
l'électricité et là sur l'éducation
c'est qu'au fond vous le dites vous-même
vous avait alerté souvent et on en est
là presque au pied du mur au delà de la
question de la pénurie de profs il ya
aussi la question des conditions dans
lesquelles ils travaillent à la question
bien sûr des salaires mais aussi ce
témoignage qui interroge ce livre qui a
été relayée notamment dans le parisien
samuel pâtit ça aurait pu être moi voilà
le livre consignes à un professeur qui
reste anonyme par peur de représailles
les professeurs de lettres comme vous
l'avez été agrégées en 1990 prof en
banlieue parisienne et il raconte les
coups de boutoir islamistes au quotidien
auquel il fait face
et il raconte surtout la solitude des
professeurs ils parlent de tabous sur la
shoah il dit par exemple que voltaire il
ne peut plus enseigner parce que trop
anticlérical ou jugés trop anticlérical
par des élèves est ce que ça aussi ça
vous inquiète
le
l'administration des de chaque
établissement doit être en situation de
soutien pour chaque enseignant et il
doit y avoir une possibilité d' alerte
immédiate pour chaque enseignant qui se
trouve dans une situation de cet ordre
devant une classe pour qu'il y ait une
réaction immédiate
si cette alerte n'a pas pu être prise en
compte c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas je ne sais pas de quels
établissements us lagier vous considérez
sais pas ce qui ne va pas il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas apolline de malherbe
dans tous les secteurs de la société
française voulait bien à l'hôpital dans
les transports oui mais de croire qu'il
n'ya que ces dérives islamistes qui sont
le problème de la société française
c'est se tromper
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est d'une
reconstruction générale
d'une refondation comme dit le président
de la république on ne peut pas
ciblé sur un seul sujet et parce que
c'est mensonger il y a des milliers
d'établissements en france qui n'ont pas
de problème de cet ordre et qui
cependant sont en difficulté devant
l'éducation le
la stratégie générale que nous devons
adopter je suis persuadé qu'il ya une
stratégie qui existe depuis
le roussi national de la refondation il
doit aussi se pencher là dessus il doit
se pencher là dessus il doit se pencher
sur sur la mission la pénurie sur
affirmer sa capacité à enseigner sur la
question de l'efficacité de l'éducation
nationale dans la transmission des
connaissances de la culture qui fait les
hommes libres et les femmes libres qui
fait les hommes femmes au féminin et au
masculin libre
sur la question du clean a du mal être
des enseignants sur la question du
salaire
qu'on a le droit de regarder parce que
quand on regarde les vrais chiffres de
ce qu'il ya sur la feuille de paie des
enseignants etc on voit que c'est des
bac + plus on se dit qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas le compte n'y est
pas et dans un moment où l'argent public
va être de plus en plus rares françois
bey et donc eu tout ceci c'est une
mobilisation générale de la société
française pour faire face à la sig grave
crise qui vient et qui en fait je ne
sais ni dans notre pays dure depuis
40 ans la crise qui vient et qui
arrivait depuis longtemps françois
bayrou vous allez me dire que c'est
l'écumé des choses m'enfin vous à
l'instant j'ai senti que nous faisait
bien attention à préciser les hommes au
sens large hommes et femmes quand vous
entendez qu'on se pose des questions sur
le sexe du barbecue en quelque sorte
est-ce que vous c'est vous qui faites le
barbecue l'infini non d'abord donc non
mais
qu'est ce qu'il doit nous verser la
société française aujourd'hui non mais
c'est ce sont des questions qui sont
profondément dérangeantes parce que
95% des français les ressentent comme
des questions de n'importe quoi comme
une une espèce de dérive de dévoiement
de questions légitimes la situation des
femmes et des hommes dans la société
c'est une question légitime et quand on
voit que simplement pour
créer
de l'émotion du scandale de deux des
débats infinis on
affirme des choses aussi
choquant que la différence entre les
hommes et les femmes dans la
consommation de viande et qu'on veut en
faire un principe d'organisation de la
société française c'est à dire qu'on
veut que l'état aille se mêler de ce
qu'il ya dans votre assiette que l'état
se mêle de la manière dont se
répartissent les tâches ménagères
vous avez entendu qu'on voulait faire
enfin que certains voulaient faire ou
certaines voulaient faire une loi sur ce
sujet avec des réponses pénales pour
vous est pas le rôle des politiques
c'est pas seulement que ce n'est pas le
rôle des politiques ce sont des
questions de diversion
nous avons devant nous des himalaya à
gravir pour que le pays retrouve enfin
on retrouve la force la puissance la
capacité de réponse qui doit être les
siennes et ont des vies la réflexion de
la société sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets être considérée par 90% des
français comme ridicule mais vous l'avez
dit comme comme dévalorisant comme si
c'était une manière de de transformer
l'esprit civique en
en
divertissement sans intérêt françois
bayrou nous avons des himalaya à gravir
voilà ce que vous nous dites ce matin à
vous qui êtes haut commissaire au plan
et président du modem merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions ce matin d'avoir
sonné le signal d'alarmé